the gods will use you
but they will not help you
there is no
tunnel reward for us
Gore is a terrifying villain
all of us were a little bit like
actually scared
hey managers just don't pull the Focus
right into that moment and you can't
take your eyes off him you kind of team
Gore he's terrifying he's funny he's
oddly Charming minus the dental issues
and he does that thing that I think
Marvel villains do so well that your
villainary comes from Pain
how exciting
but these films it's really difficult to
try and figure out a what the story is
is it original does it feel fun does it
fit within the MCU and one of the
hardest things always is figuring out
what the villain is and what he wants
I think the Thor franchise has a history
of producing some pretty interesting
villains so it was very important for us
to introduce another terrifying villain
and we found that in gor the god butcher
we were looking at the source material
from the comics Jason Aaron takes over
the book most recently and tells the
story of Gore the god butcher there are
Illusions in the design to the design
from the comics but it's the character
as a whole that we're trying to emulate
those monologues that point of view that
betrayal that Gore feels was Central to
the character you are no good
I renounce you